what on Earth am I looking at Alana what
am I looking at Austin suck Mike a
little bit okay so you did Master roshi
I got it thank you I didn't think any of
you would get it
I was like there's no way then you're
recording that I am recording yes
I've even got the little turtle shell
backpack you have the audacity I have
the audacity I don't have the audacity
that's the problem like you look
fabulous
very good
oh yeah make a boy feel special
half an hour
it's like it's like dripped the wires
out of uh some kind of unused utility
it's like definitely not meant for this
purpose it feels like you've got you've
got like an unworking I didn't realize
that they actually lit up sorry I've got
a little light arms
on this hey by the way
um bartender downstairs had a little bit
of a sassy attitude and they're kind of
into it he I said hey man uh I want a
glass of that he goes I can't do that
I'm like you can I believe in you he
said no it has to be by the bottles like
all right [ __ ] it give me the bottle and
then he goes in Earnest he says do you
want a glass or a straw
[Laughter]
imagine that you're also not traveling
and that you're at home and you just
have a bar in like the living room of
your house
this is yeah
I love this so much so Troy are you just
playing Troy Baker
uh like on the road
we haven't really seen the real Troy Bay
no he's doing what I said it's a
chameleon you just put a scarf on and
you become Booker to it it's perfect
yeah this is [ __ ] this is I quit
I I realized like I had this I had to on
on the on the other side of this on the
front side of this trip I was like this
is gonna be great I was supposed to be
here with my family this is a metal
straw
I was supposed to be your family
and they're not yeah because the [ __ ]
about the ocean
um and then
I do
I really do I stopped eating I care
about the ocean so much yeah
I just I stopped eating Seafood yeah and
now they're like there's the the ocean
is the Plenty
um I I was supposed to be here with my
family I I shot this thing for about a
month and then I I was like okay I'm
gonna hang on because at the end of when
this thing airs I'm going to be in
London for MCM Comic-Con
y'all pull up
um and then I go home and then the the
interval between that was gonna be this
wistful wonderful thing and it's not and
I'm just been on the road too long
um
I was I'm very
drinking wine through a straw out here
that's how I'm doing yeah I went to Bath
yesterday
hmm love ice I stayed in a haunted uh
hotel that's cool Lauren boss yeah
it was annoying
it was actually annoying the ghost kept
you up damn damn Spectros
yeah they were just
probably hotel management uh to file a
complaint um Austin I would like to file
a complaint about the hoodie what's
what's this yeah well because I didn't
know this was coming I am a Mass Effect
fan
who's a playwatch listen fan
but also
very fancy
uh it's also it's book of DeWitt as a
play watch listen Mass Effect fan wow
level twists were experience
would you kindly
you have to commit to this which means
oh I'm the full Joey Tribbiani right now
this situation it actually kind of looks
good weirdly well I can tell you it's
Alan Wake Now isn't it it's Alan Wake
with the hoodie I feel like in the
jacket yeah I feel like I look like
Richard Riley in um office space you
know after he's in his car accident he's
in the severe uh like head brace a
million dollars
guys I just re-watched that recently and
it is every bit as funny as it was 20
years ago
I love it it's a jump
inside of me
space is a little old for me a lot so
like we uh okay okay no so people have
brought that movie up to me so many
times recently I haven't seen it but I
guess it's like the foundation of a
bunch of people's senses of humor
yeah it's where it's where you if you
can draw a straight line from that's
like Kevin Smith to like Millennial I
did recently watch Blazing Saddles so
don't don't try to make up for this
by the way congratulations you all
Bremner I've just put together Troy
you're you're doing Westworld aren't you
that's what it is
you got it nailed it there you go
this is a Roy shark test if I said
something different would you have been
like nailed it also uh Mike is doing uh
the epitome of Tron I believe
I am the very best
right now what that actually means is
that Mike is once again just bidding
wish listing uh that's the costume it's
it is a i it is a
sponsored
yeah sponsored content I did try I used
to do money bags Mike
um I I was gonna wear like I said that
was this this was
this is my best bike and I was gonna get
a top hat and a monocle but it turns out
it's actually harder to get a top hat
than you would think and a lot of them
are very expensive
[Laughter]
yeah you're not going on Amazon for that
I also think that Mike looks like a
total super villain right now like he is
100 yeah
unlike normal yeah you you look more
like David Warner than you do anybody
one of my favorite lines by the way in
Tron I have the lines that I quote from
the movie 1982 is that right 82.
um there's two lines that I quote that
don't match up at all he goes stop I
need that and he's there's nothing to
which has been referred to at all but
David Warner is leaning back and the
continuity is bad because he's not
leaning back in the second shot it's
amazing
and then my old account of something
missing that was removed uh that sounds
like a dropped shot or a dropped partial
line or something it's just it's just
directors going we're not sure what the
scene is going to look like you can just
tell that it was kind of like I don't
know and David Warner is in a I mean
1982 probably shot in an 81. he's in a
green screen and he's talking to uh
something that's not there I totally
relate I totally understand the time
where there's no reference point for
that wait wait no reason I need that was
a reference to something that would have
been cut is what you're saying
stop I need that was David Warner's line
in response to Master Control
saying that he would
he's asserting his powers like you think
you can do this without me hahaha and he
goes stop I need that but he doesn't say
what he needs but he has like it's so
strange and then he's like leaning way
back when the second shot he's not
and so it's just like this weird
continuity but the ultimate one is
God damn bruised box Lightner coming up
and going
we made it
[Laughter]
this far
watch it it is the best
Shatner would look at that and go that's
a long time I won't hear a bad word
against my close personal friend Bruce
Lee we sat in uh I love it he's lovely
bloke oh you're gonna say my close
personal friend Tron he was like yeah
you're at that level now even Toronto
you do get to meet trump
it is it is
I agree David Warner like this is nice
we've we've put we've put we've put a
nice old David Warner Easter egg in
there like I loved around well done I
wonder how Bruce feels about this
because I mean obviously when people
think Tron they think Jeff Bridges
yeah but Bruce Bruce Boxley was the the
titular character right so it he well
who this is that was unintentional but
perfect that was that was BD
um but it's it's it is very interesting
to me I wonder how he feels about that
as far as being slighted because I I
can't think of another movie where the
hero was
kind of like one upped by
the the side character because at that
point
introduce himself to me as TV actor
Bruce boxline that so like I was like
yes I like the guy immediately like
based on that like he's definitely yeah
I knew him from scarecrow and Mrs King
which nobody outside the U.S knows what
that show is but like including at least
one person from the US from the U.S you
may have imagined I'm not sure that
exists
100 scarecrow Mrs King there was this
whole like thing in the 80s where it was
what happens if we put you know this we
flipped the rolls and it's like she's
she's the staunch you know business
woman and he's the wacky do guy and it
didn't really work because you had
Remington Steel
you had which is a great purpose for a
show yeah
as well and then Moon Lighting hit and
that's where it was like that's the
magic sauce up until the point where
they had sex and it was like I don't
know we don't watch it anymore because
there's attention
damn you have to go back to our new
learning is an amazing field and it made
Bruce every movie or TV show the minute
they [ __ ] now there's no tension
his wife
yeah yeah it's still unclear things have
been really tough since Traveler
yeah she's like there's no there's no
tension in there
we're great how are you we never fight
there's no problem as soon as you have
sex with your wife it's boring for the
audience but it's great for us pretty
much what that's why I have so many ring
cameras I'm starting my own network I'm
live on the ring Network
every morning Austin I wanted to ask uh
this is sort of an aside because I
didn't watch any of it
um would you like to convince me that
Andor is good
I haven't watched it yet
that's fine I refused I put my foot down
and was like I can't do any more Star
Wars I can't watch anymore I just keep
getting angry because I really didn't
like the last two serieses and I didn't
I felt like I was becoming the angry
Star Wars Reddit guy because I was
getting really pissed off about it so I
actually like I even privated some
videos about Star Wars that I had made
because I was so negative about Star
Wars Mo it was mostly or private private
I want to make sure everything okay but
it was mostly the book of the stupid
book of Beth but I also like didn't like
Obi-Wan very much and then like people
who are part of that audience who you
would definitely not want on your side
assumed that I was on their side because
I strongly disliked the stuff so I was
like oh I don't like any of this
um so I didn't watch Andor because I was
like I can't believe the trailers I
don't want to buy into it again
but I heard but why get angry about it
like what's the point of that like it's
not intentional
it's not a not not wanted
quite the case Austin
so go ahead
the long deliberate pause so what the
hell is that
um
yeah I heard I also heard myself back
for a second we had a little wonderful
technology moment there I was starting
to say my dramatic pause is going to
look like deliberate thinking but it's
more that it's I think just hard to
breathe in this thing but um
all right carry on the um in this
episode Mike bithle spontaneously
combust I think he and I are in a race
to spontaneous yeah
I think the UK is probably a little bit
colder
I've been overseas and I I was in
Switzerland and then I came home on
Sunday and I walked outside and I was
like oh slightly crisp because I'm used
to just being in Switzerland when were
you in Switzerland I was only there for
like less than 24 hours uh Saturday and
Sunday me too I was in Geneva I was in
Zurich
oh you're the German side by the way I
if anybody's been paying attention I've
been doing a tour of everyone's
grandmother's bedroom right now the
hotel that I stayed in in Switzerland
was
um
ugly as [ __ ]
um but there was a guy who knocked on
the door and said hi it's the Butler and
I was like what and he was like the
chocolate Butler you get free chocolate
every day and I was like what and so
this man dressed in this suit with this
hat gave me like my he had this cart and
he gave me whatever Swiss chocolate I
wanted
if you're ever in Switzerland if you
find anybody on the street that was like
here
eat it because it's the best [ __ ]
chocolate you'll ever be like
that
I don't speak for the show there no that
is not the official stance
don't take anything from Strange's [ __ ]
you know what I'll go I took this candy
from a stranger I never met this person
in my life who gave this to me and I
know that it's gonna be the best
chocolate I've ever he has officially
joined the race full combustion and this
is how it starts who will die
it's very Halloween of us
I bet I bet it's good anyway andal I
think too many people try to
uh
[Music]
cyanide laced coffee right out just
right out
um he needs the uh Nicholas Cage you
want me to put this needle into my heart
do you think he went to vomit again
the real commitment will be if literally
the next 30 minutes goes by
if he can keep it going for half an hour
that will be genuinely or what point do
he starts work it's the little
reflection of him crouched down in the
window oh can you see him
I got excited
the only the only way to do it the only
way I could have topped that is if you
had your head Rising so slowly in frame
that it took a solid 30 minutes like if
you had the sort of muscle control to
just read yeah try do better uh yeah
bring a little bit more into the show
isn't it
performance lacking in technical skills
very good directive note there there
Mike Bethel
if you're in London by the way I left
the interval
um which is not my review
I did it because I wanted to make sure I
was on time and uh but I finally saw the
play that goes wrong
oh yeah yeah yeah has that not made it
to America yet is that not I would
assume that would be well maybe it has I
could give this [ __ ] though
super good all right
Austin please
and all please get your thoughts out for
the love of God I know thank you for I
made your patience and bearing with me
yeah
so by the way there was something great
like the the Apollo the Apollo probe is
uh you know uh careening so I have to
loosen my time to look like a stressed
late night NASA great scientific yeah
that's allowed sorry go ahead okay go
ahead and or
and I need six words or less I need the
uh I need like Ed Harris glasses yeah I
had a lot of sweat yeah
so
um my did you know that Ed Harris
it'll never not be funny
so never this will be the finale of this
uh like 20 minutes from now oh and by
the way do you remember last episode
Austin where we had that lovely chat and
we kind of Let each other speak and we
kind of did you interrupt her stuff it's
really great not at all it was wonderful
it was good it was a it was a uh what's
the term conversation
very uh very Charming that was also that
feels like 50 years ago
editorial only two weeks how weird you
guys want to see what it looks like when
you have a hotel to your laundry
oh they give you little bags don't they
so wonderful left turn there
oh very nice that looks like it looks
like I went to prison like I went to
prison and they're like here are your
effects well that's a fancy prison
that's a fancy prison I followed it for
you bud it sucks yeah you're right
that's true it uh reminds you Amanda
like you bought it's like you went to
like a like a um you know like a um
vending machine store it turns out like
prefab socks outfits this is the Tribeca
so all right so here's my thoughts
um I think there are people that say I
I've seen the review it's a good show
but it's not really Star Wars oh I don't
care and that I think
there's part of me that fully
understands and even in a way kind of
agrees with that assessment which is why
if I if I if I lean into my the part of
me that agrees with that because there's
other part of me that goes it's actually
it's actually a beautifully returned to
form for Star Wars but I'll get to that
in a second if I lean into the argument
that it's good but it's it's like it's
not Star Wars enough but it's like
independently of Star Wars a good show I
feel like that was that is what that's
why I think you should
sort of walk back your your band as it
were because it is such a palette
cleanse it's like a Str I mean the
literally I've there's been how many six
episodes seven episodes seven now I
think I think the one before the last
one
was basically the first one where had it
been any other show what happened would
have been in the pilot episode they
spent like five hours building to the
thing that most people would have been
like no one cares about all this
[ __ ] let's just cut straight through
in a good way in a very good way like to
me I love it it's far and away my
favorite Star Wars since since Rogue one
which are the collectively the two Far
and Away favorite things of the modern
era yeah okay so I I have a question
pursuant to that notion of it's not
starworthy what does that even mean
anymore I so I got into this argument
with someone with an argument a debate
on this a little while ago
it was a conversation I just feel like I
just titled the the so the answers the
question is yeah by the reason so I had
a chat with someone who was it's now a
chat uh with someone who was like it's
not Star Wars and I think what the I get
the perspective because it's basically
it's not really a western it's not
really a Serial action show it's not
really there's there's no lightsabers
there's no it's it's kind of there
hasn't even been a single mention of the
force wow so I read I something that
something that I heard or even like ref
like they don't not only
spoilery I've even seen us we've not
even seen a spaceship in space yet
that's the thing that someone pointed
out that was like that is mind-blowing
wow six episodes in
um or I am six episodes in but no it's a
it's a political thriller it's it's a
someone that's taking itself to a very
serious level it feels like you're
watching uh Peak TV a friend of mine
you know the um Jean the Carr uh novels
like Tinker Taylor Soldier Spy they said
it's basically a Star Wars rendition of
Tinker Taylor solder spy it's a it's
about paranoia it's about it's about
like the mutual paranoia that a
rebellion and the Imperial authorities
kind of have in internally and
externally which is very much a cold war
style Thrillers show about war
yeah so would you say that it's really
good if someone let's think of Lana
whatever I I would even pull it back and
say someone who just doesn't have that
strong of a position on Star Wars
whether because I I understand like I
don't get angry about it because I'm
just too old to care but I the Patton
Oswald has a great thing is like I don't
hate any music anymore in my 20s and 30s
I'd be like I will tell you to clarify I
hate almost nothing except for the
[ __ ] book of Boba Fett foreign
my question is is would you say that
this is for someone who is either like
I'm out of the Star Wars thing
um which I I was kind of that way it's
like Mandalorian cool and then I I it it
locks the question I know you're going
towards which is basically would you
recommend this to someone who doesn't
like Star Wars and I had someone who I
was showing someone the other day or
does it know anything about Star Wars it
doesn't know anything about stars I was
talking to someone the other day who's
not watched anything Star Wars since I
think the last of the Empire Trilogy
yeah yeah I lost the sequel Trilogy was
just like it's not for me I'm I'm
walking away kind of thing and and there
was they were saying should I watch Like
Mandalorian the show which Android I was
like Mandalorian is like distilled
concentrated Star Wars like if you're a
Star Wars fan Mandalorian is the Star
Wars that's all the Star Wars things you
like done really well and entertainingly
and it's got a cool theme tune it's it's
a really good Star Wars
and or feels like something that
actually is
something completely else and it's
something that kind of expands the
extent on it and the the one viewing tip
I'd give that I heard or I read I read
an article about it that the the the the
the shows basically and this this again
just shows the level of respect they're
treating the material with
each three episode block is written by
and directed by the same people so you
so what we've been doing is we've been
waiting for them to come out in threes
and Austin will back me up here like
each of those the three the chunks of
three feel like they are meant to be
watched together so I would recommend it
and it's 12 episodes
yeah that's the way that midnight mass
was uh directed Mike Flanagan said I
believe was like that it's supposed to
be like a series of of films rather than
uh TV and I think that's like a thing
that I don't like about Mandalorian
while I actually think Mandalorian is a
good show I stopped watching it because
I it's hard for something that's like
serial to retain me but there isn't a
through line or a character who's
heading towards one specific goal I tend
to just lose interest and I I think more
episodic this is episode like episodes
are three episodes long I would say it's
got like there's definitely you could
definitely watch episodes three through
five four through five four four through
six sorry without having seen episodes
one two three I think so
I don't know
yeah I mean that's a lot of that's all
that it is it's all character Focus
that's why the that the other thing I'll
just throw in real quick and then Troy
you were about to say something to a lot
of but the thing I'll add in about the
whole like one of the complaints that I
see in my community is
um there's no question that what's your
community like the the world of
composers okay yeah that makes sense
sorry
of that very valid thing [ __ ] you you're
cute
I have other friends you know no no no
but uh
the score for Andor is done by Nick
bratel who's most well known for
um uh succession and a bunch of other
things and it is
like this is the thing that's hard to
come out it feels like a HBO show yeah
that's the thing
it doesn't feel Star Wars it's not
really orchestral music at all there's a
few moments where it actually does
borderline on that Troy not in a Cheesy
way but a little Imperial March in
episode six that I loved they had like a
little Imperial March just play they're
playing underneath it just a little bit
it's very very so like and I've seen a
lot of people say that the score the
kind of Space Opera you know kind of
melodramatic orchestral sensibility of
John Williams is a definitive quality of
what makes things Star warsy as like in
it and that this show to me I applaud
even though the music to me is largely
uh it's it's so subtly used you don't
really retain anything by and large
about it but I see that as an admirable
let's burn it all to the ground and
build afresh you know build Anew and I
think the courage it takes to do that on
a multi-billion dollar franchise
especially one that's been on such a
everything is about Nostalgia you know
it was like but Mandalorian was
Nostalgia with a dash of novelty and
then Boba Fett was like let's just get
rid of the dash and then Obi-Wan was
like we'll show you how to get rid of
the dash so it was like everything was
just doubling down harder and harder and
harder and harder on the Nostalgia
remember the trilogy was the same member
berries 100 this isn't like that at all
like like you don't even like they they
um they they this is not really a
spoiler but but um there's a minor thing
that is just so worth pointing out about
the crafts the craftsmanship
no like they they you spend the whole
first few episodes is just like watching
this Scrappy rag tag like proto-rebel
Alliance folks before the Rebellion
really exists you know spending months
and months and months planning what and
any other thing would be a modest
operation and they keep talking about oh
we have to worry about you know there's
an Imperial Air Base and finally it's
like three episodes in a single TIE
fighter flies by and it feels like a
huge [ __ ] deal it actually feels
scary it actually doesn't feel like some
disposable Pawn One of a million that
can be killed off and it feels like that
thing is a [ __ ] military piece of
equipment and a single one of them doing
a flyby scares the [ __ ] out of these
people and it's like boy it's been a
long time since Star Wars felt anything
like that sounds kind of cool and I
think that's white it's wonderful that's
also production design I love all things
Disney makes obviously I particularly
love handle well it's also just really
really well shot and it feels like they
built really huge sets and they're not
relying on the volume and all that kind
of stuff it's the space the the space
that the first few episodes take place
in like space Manchester basically is
just fundamentally just massive and
beautiful yeah it's I would I would
strongly recommend it one of my
struggles I think with watching it
um is something that like you've
alleviated my concerns regarding here is
I feel like I just keep watching so much
IP content when I watch TV because I
don't watch a lot of TV and I feel like
I'm just watching IP content of the same
[ __ ] over and over and over again and if
I only have a small amount of time to
watch TV I want to watch succession or
whatever
um and I think that was part of the
problem with Star Wars was that I felt
like I was I was in some of those other
series as watching advertising or like
watching something that's like trying to
sell me on a brand yeah um or a universe
or like it's still an IP but Interview
with a Vampire is really good as well if
you're not sorry watching that I've seen
a lot of tweets about that
but um that does sound like it's away
from that like
what's going on here that's all right uh
sorry Troy what are you gonna what are
you gonna ask
number one it looks like you have a
testicle on your head
um that's not a question we were all
thinking it
um I don't remember what the question
was from a long time ago that was years
ago
um yeah sorry that's on me
we took you that long to get you to
answer the question I think you're okay
I think I was gonna say if you were like
if it's not if there's not like a
through line if there's not a single
character that's
moving towards a goal does that mean
that like anthological content areas I
oversold that aspect of it that 100 is
right but yeah
do you not then
um like like anthological content or do
you like what is it I really like Black
Mirror but I think I look at that as a
series of films
um I think again
I have a uh trouble watching a lot of TV
because it really doesn't feel
productive I recognize that that doesn't
really make any sense
um I prefer to spend my time playing
video games because at least that feels
productive because I feel like I'm
always like trying to learn things about
the industry that I work in by playing
video games so like stay informed or
whatever so I have a lot of trouble
watching TV unless I am very emotionally
invested uh hold on I would love I would
love to to this ping something for me
because I remember talking to a friend
and he said that he young kid he wanted
to because he wanted to be an actor and
a director and you know it's like so I
need to go to film school he's like I
don't want to just work at a coffee shop
and and do that I want to do this
because as a writer I want to learn the
skill of writing I'm like
you you learn how to be a writer by
experiencing a human condition and I
can't imagine a better place for you to
be than be at a coffee shop where you're
face to face 100 day
so I think that sometimes I I've seen
this within my own self I have the
tendency to get a little too insular and
look at just the world in which I
operate as opposed to a long time ago a
friend of mine told me it was like if
you ever find yourself
struggling for right brain activity you
should really probably exercise your
left brain because there's a balance
that needs to happen so if all you're
doing is video games video games video
games video game
that's not helping your industry but
it's nice what I'm saying is like I find
it hard to get through a lot of TV
because it doesn't feel productive so
the challenge that I have which is a
challenge that I've had like for a long
time that I need to figure out is I
struggle to do things if I do not feel
like they are productive uh which like
I'd love to be able to sit down and
watch TV but it doesn't feel productive
in my head uh but I still watch TV it's
that I have to be selective so like if
I'm only going to watch one series a
month
should it be Star Wars four times like I
feel like that is limiting for creative
thinking uh if I'm just watching the
same branded thing every time which I
was doing
um and I I again I just I want to watch
succession like I haven't watched The
Sopranos I want to watch this
what about succession really because
after like the second season what what
about it for like the the third season
or whatever really grabbed you I haven't
seen any of it
I've not oh meaning it's all your life
yeah it's like the top of my list but I
haven't and yeah
[Music]
it's shitty people uh from my
understanding that
um uh still I don't know interesting
enough to hold an entire show and I was
like that's something that I haven't
seen before like I just I want to watch
that I don't know it seems like what
you're saying it's also it's fascinating
because it's a comedy in terms of it's
written by it's the peep show two
British rights to do the peep show right
and it's basically so it's also the the
show runner they've been treated very
seriously yeah Will Ferrell's show but
like it's super serious and that kind of
Will Ferrell is the showrunner of
succession he's exposed
yeah I don't think I've ever known that
yeah it's it's he and uh who's the guy
he's always Trucking with what's his
name
um comedy writer um
yes working together recently yeah yeah
yeah no 15 people are screaming at me
right now what's his name he's done all
those movies I know I know what you mean
[ __ ] anyway
yes Mel Brooks
um
I
have nothing to say I think
Alana I think you're
um I think the kind of summary of what
you were saying is that you prefer to
kind of let the filtering of what has
naturally risen as a like a real
legitimate Contender and instead of
trying to be on the front lines of oh
the latest thing is out let's go see how
it is you you preferred a way to beat
for people to to like and if enough
people go like if I'm the ninth person
to recommend and or yeah then you go
okay you know what uh that one's
probably now gonna get on the list
alongside these others sure yeah that's
interesting so I'm definitely the flip
of that like I will go and try the first
episode of everything so I want to be
the guy who finds the thing that and
recommends it I'm like that with games
I'll play Everything
I watch a lot of movies
I I'm a little bit different like I I
feel like right now the way that you
can't just watch a show you have to
you have to watch it immediately we've
gotten we've gone back to event viewing
and if you haven't watched it the minute
that it aired
you're out of the loop and like it
doesn't it doesn't really bother me
either like from a spoilers perspective
yeah because like you know House of
dragons or whatever um I I was like I
somebody tweeted about this or whatever
they said it's really hard to follow a
show where every character's name Aragon
aegon Mega it's just like they recall
them every couple of episodes as well
for that first yeah so annoying man but
it's it's all I understand a lot of what
you're saying as far as like I feel like
I'm watching it's it I would say it's a
circus as opposed to an act it's like
this whole thing to where it's like
there's more derivative content about
the thing than there is the thing
so there's things are often designed to
encourage that as well right sure see a
lot which which to me effectively are
encouraging that circus to form around
them that says to me that the real thing
the real product is not the content the
real product is the conversation
because that's really what people want
that's that's that's what Humanity wants
we want to be able to discuss it we want
discourse about it we want to argue
about it we want to find a community
that's right I've been Reinventing the
opportunity but I suppose I also feel
like a lot of those conversations have
just become
um exhausting recently like like the
house of dragons and
uh Lord of the Rings are like not
conversations I want to be a part of
um and just see people screaming at each
other
well I just I everybody's like here's
how it disappointed me right like who
gives a [ __ ] but yeah you're allowed to
express that but I I'm gonna I think the
right way to do these conversations is
way that you did Alana a minute ago
where you go sell me on and or like
because I would love for a die-hard fan
of rings of power to sell me on it
because I really really wanted to and I
was like I'm bouncing off this hard uh
like this is really made a lot of
decisions that I I I just can't parse
and I'm but I'm always willing to
entertain the idea that there's
something I don't see especially in the
case of that one because I'm not one of
these hardcore Tolkien fans that's like
you know kind of got a wider view of it
I'm basically just looking at it face
value as a show and as like a fan I read
the books and I read I read I watched
the films but I you know my mind tends
to think about other things so it's like
nothing would please me more than for
someone who thinks it's just amazing to
sell me on it Beyond just like oh I like
liked it but like here's the thing you
missed that would be awesome I think I
think I always had the same problem less
so with Lord of the Rings but definitely
with um
House of dragons where I watched the
first two episodes and then was like
this is more of the show that I already
watched for eight seasons so it's the
exact same thing that I was like it's
not saying it's not good there were a
lot of things that I liked about it but
I was like I've seen something let's say
seasons of this exact thing before my
time is limited and I just stopped
wanting to watch it
um I I mean I watch a lot of
documentaries like virtually every
documentary that shows up on Netflix I
will watch but I I don't know I think
the saturation of ips is something that
I recognize is not going anywhere uh I
have a question yes how does that I'm
just curious how that makes you feel
productive knowledge I'm directly
learning about something
again I need to be very clear I
recognize that this is irrational that
my obsession with productivity is not
rooted in logic it's a it's like it's
irrational
I I have it from the opposite side but I
don't play as many video games as I
should because if I'm intellectually
able to like do something interactive I
would just rather make a video game like
so for me I do a lot I watch a lot more
movies and TV because for me
entertainment time is like when I'm not
if I'm if I'm on the ball enough to
engage with a video game I just want to
go and code something you know what I
mean so it's kind of a similar thing but
from the other hand
I I propose that I I I will say I I can
kind of I can kind of relate to that
Mike but I have to say the loophole that
I've been really grateful for is
the fact that dice has asked me to um
to kind of
periodically co-host their game makers
notebook podcast because the only reason
I get to play most stuff is just yeah
like towards come around to have to
actually play I Love It I do interviews
with people in order to know what their
new release is and to you know to be
able to talk about it like I I did one
the other day with um Ron Gilbert so I
was like you know very excited to play
through the new Monkey Island
um I was excited anyway but it kind of
It kind of sped it up in my I did the
same thing I I uh I play through it
because I interviewed Dominic
[Laughter]
I have to say I really liked it
um I I uh I point-and-click Adventures
were very much like my home base genre
growing up the Sierra games on the one
hand and the LucasArts
um games you know all the Monkey Island
particular but like obviously Grim
Fandango I'm kind of obsessed with but
um Full Throttle in the Dig and Maniac
Mansion day the tentacle they're all
great and all the space quests and
police quests and a lot a lot of that
and this one to me felt just novel
enough to not be a member Barry's thing
but it was clearly a kind of let's
continue
um let's continue that lineage like
let's not let's not be
um
let's not overly worry about if the
genre needs a total revision
um like it's okay to to say let's start
in that territory
um and kind of push forward I loved that
he included I'm curious your thoughts on
this specifically as a writer the fact
that the game has a toggleable writer's
cut that like sometimes dialogue and
stuff Monkey Island does yeah literally
there's a feature in the menu that says
basically if you want a slightly more
succinct game
um you can you can like uncheck The
Writer's cut
um this is just in the new one I'm
talking about the return of monkeys yeah
this was folded around my teeth
can we talk about vampire survivors hang
on I wanted to say uh that's the thing
that's an idea of a writer's cut of
something that like um I guess I had
forgotten you yeah that like the idea of
like a toggle where you could experience
a game or a certain parts of it or just
completely remove others like I think we
spoke about it in terms of like Puzzles
or gameplay that maybe you just take
them out what does that mean I know I
can tell you I asked because I played it
with I I wanted the full thing I did it
on like the hard the quote hard mode The
Writer's cut I was like I want whatever
is the fullest most bloated version of
this I can get my hands on either one
it's a toggle it's it's an option in the
game
um yeah I've looked at it all right I'll
look at it again oh you have to like if
you launch and go to the minute so I
asked him like what's uh what is a um an
example of a thing that changes based on
the writer's cut like as I said how do
you when so many of the puzzles are
built around dialogue and clues come
from what people say how do you edit
that uh because it didn't feel like
there was piles of superfluous
side you know the equivalent of like a
BioWare game where you're like oh I
might romance this person and there's a
bunch of stuff that's not really core to
the advancing the story but it's there
to marinate the the gameplay uh they he
said as an example
um one of the most explicit examples was
when you go to melee Island at the
beginning the original Three pirate
leaders have been kind of kicked out of
the bar and they're standing in the
middle of the street kind of away from
it and you can talk to them and he said
if you have the writer's Cut Thing
disabled they're just not there that
whole that whole ability to interact
with them is gone because it's not
actually required and so players who
like there's some subset of players that
might interact with them think they're
looking for like oh this is going to be
a clue for later and then if it turns
out that it was nothing there it just
feels like Hollow you know dead air so
they said we can cut things like that or
you know even specific lines or shorten
conversations
I think it's cool I think the because
the alternative is not that the game
would have been longer the or would have
had more writing like it's that that all
would have been cut like the only thing
that would have shipped would have been
the short version right so it's not like
they've made Choice yes that would be
the right choice yes so it would have
been shorter so the toggle is adding
content technically not removing content
um and I think that's cool for players
who want different things like I'm
totally I'm trying to think if that's if
that's ever happened in like film the
only one I can example director's cut is
kind of that isn't it
well that's your but that's director's
cut rather than like I'm thinking like
sorry like
um
well well there's an example there's is
um the Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
um Tarantino wrote a novelization and
the novelization because novelizations
back in the day for films would often be
based on a script so they'd have scenes
in them that were not in the movies
um because that would suffocate cutter
will change or whatever so they'd often
be discrepancies and he's played into
that with that book and deliberately
written it with a bunch of scenes that
are not in the movie you know and
there's lots of stuff in that book which
he never said he never wrote and it's a
really it's a really interesting book
because it basically just adds so much
so much depth that you kind of didn't
get when you watched that movie I
suppose uh often times that it is that
in reverse a book version like if a
book's written in a movie's adapted from
the book then the book is technically
the writer's Cuts that's a really good
point
here's a question for half of our
quadrant
do you direct from the page or do you
intentionally write this is definitely
do you well actually there's actually in
some way does apply to you however I I
feel like however I don't give a [ __ ]
what you have to say yeah no it's fine
it's fine carry on
because I think that I'm I want to see
if I want to flex a little bit because
this either goes to your orchestrator or
goes to your copyist Austin
if you were to write something that says
um fortissimo or
Allegro or whatever
um that is open to interpretation so you
are saying that this needs to be played
such a way but you're allowing for that
musician to be able to interpret that as
they will based upon their knowledge of
the same word you're both agreeing on
this thing
as Writers Do you guys both write on the
page so that you present that to not
just actors but everybody else who's
going to
um extrapolate that page out to their
level design into their world design
into their
um whatever their specific
function within the the piece is
or do you try to make it as specific as
possible so that there is less
interpretation for that
I always do it collaboratively so I
would be like what does that mean though
um what is that collaborative because it
means that I've literally written it in
well yeah uh
to start with then before it gets to the
actor because there's a lot that happens
before the actor
absolutely obviously um I would write it
and be like oh well
level design we'll we'll figure
something out here like literally like
the uh like there is space on the page
for well combat or do something with
this how do you fit into that process do
you when you're because I know how it
works on kind of r scale but like are
you writing stuff before there's like a
gray box of the level or are you very
reactive are you working writing to it
while they're gray boxing like what's
the difference all of the above so yeah
you originate some writing before the
gray boxes I think I think I've said
this before on the show but my uh job is
a lot more
um narrative design than I expected it
to be which I love because a lot of it I
don't just write a script A lot of it
does have to be how will this be
interpreted by the player and what is
this going to look like in terms of
gameplay and all of that um which is
super fun how does it sync up with
gameplay how does gameplay speak to this
and then how does narrative I mean the
coolest thing about working at somewhere
like Santa Monica Studios everyone's so
[ __ ] good at what they do that
anything that you do that you take to
another like departmental part of the
team or whoever you're working with no
matter what they're going to give you
ideas that are way better than
everything you had so like every it's
almost every day I go holy [ __ ] that's
so cool like just because of someone I
work with is really good at what they do
so I would never always right yeah and I
think actors are exactly the same like
when when it comes to
time where the actor is reading the
words
they're gonna bring you a bunch of cool
[ __ ] that you never thought of that's
gonna make the character better I think
that like
it would be really dumb especially on a
video game of such a large scale to
expect your words to just be perfect
from the get-go not necessarily perfect
but just to speak to that I do know that
there's a lot of times when it's
oh okay so the the intention that I put
behind this was so that you know it's
kind of important that you say it this
way oh I do do that I do do like
sarcastic or like
uh to the the One Direction that I've
never done in any other kind of writing
um it's you say who it's directed to
like like right
um character says go this way but who
are they saying it to so that it's clear
I think that's who that is
myself onto a cassette player and I hold
it up to the actors there as their
delivery recipes
uh for the record uh I think the other
big well I was just gonna add a little
thing like one of the fundamental
differences I think between that kind of
writing and my kind of writing to the
point that you brought up Troy is that
if uh if if the underlying goal is to
write music that's scary and I have
decided as the composer that loud and
ferocious is going to be how I get to
scary there isn't a wiggle room in a
typical situation for a musician to go I
actually think scary is really quiet and
unnerving so I think it fortissimo
should be pianissimo in the way that
you're doing it in the way that like an
actor might go what if what if I get
what if I whisper the line instead of I
shout it like that is a much more viable
play that can happen in a director actor
scenario than a musician
whether whether it's common or whether
it's appropriate it's it it is way more
viable to me than Imagining the musical
equivalent of that of like especially if
you're looking at a 80 piece Orchestra
and one violin is like I actually think
it should be quiet instead of loud and
like everybody else's parts are aligned
understood but if it's if it's your
first chair if it's your concert master
and it's your first year at violin they
go can I show you something would you
listen to them
oh always uh but it's usually them
saying I I can I can achieve what you
have on the page like I can I can see
what in this way it is I guess an alias
where they're going I think I understand
what your goal is behind these notes and
Behind These directions on how to play
them and if we play it like this it
might achieve that but it's usually
subtle variations on it you know like
like a violinist might say do you want
me to play this off the string or on the
string which would be like you know
Boeing where they go as one unbroken
Thing versus where the bow has a little
lift in between so it's like and you
feel the separation the difference is
noticeable but it's also the kind of
Death By A Thousand Cuts like you're
making a lot of really tiny incremental
changes not oh you're right let's
rewrite the melody or something like it
you know it's right those are way bigger
more deep changes those are just a very
immediate what yes but you guys can keep
chatting if you want okay so many
thoughts on this subject yeah keep going
happy Halloween I'll just keep recording
happy Halloween everyone bye see you
later
Michael what were you gonna say I was
gonna say loads of things I I
there's a few layers to this so I think
it's partially as well she's gonna lose
in the jacket [ __ ] my boy I I think I
think it's kind of a lot what the [ __ ]
Austin thing is
God damn it
it's the bit you make the actor say is
like the last
five to ten percent of the writing job
and I think that's the 100 people always
message that they think the
collaboration is about the words on the
page it's the right writing is the
process of the planning the thinking the
working stuff out the
collaboration like for us like all our
Studios approach it's we have this
conversation a lot because then we've
been hiring a bunch of people recently
so we've had to kind of walk them
through kind of what the Bethel games
approach is with this stuff and it's and
that means thinking about it and
actually working out what the [ __ ] we
are actually going for most of the time
and I think the thing for the thing
that's kind of defined why I think our
games tell good stories is we've always
written the story around the gameplay so
you know you make Thomas Was Alone you
work out what the characters can do and
then you write a story that supports and
works around that and kind of
exaggerates and support and and builds
on top of that
um you you make a great level and then
you work out the logical story reasons
that can work you find the opportunities
you kind of you tweak you change it it
is always that kind of back and forth
with gameplay it's never that I sit down
and write a script and then deliver that
to the team and the game is made
um our medium doesn't work that way with
with the actor bits you know if you
think about like the full thrust and
this is obviously different in Triple A
but like Indie I'm making a game if I
take like two three years to make a game
I'm in the booth with actors for like a
week like it's a it's and it's a it's an
amazing privilege and it's awesome but
to me when I think about what writing is
I'll be honest I don't necessarily think
about the actors which is a really weird
thing to say but it's like no it's not
like I can completely agree like there
for months with people it's like it's
like you you've got this game and and
you know you know this tray because
we've we've I've directed you before but
it's like I come to you at a point where
there is a game I can show you the game
on a laptop you can get a sense of what
the feel of it is and you're you're
bringing your expertise to elevate that
through what you're doing but it's not
it doesn't feel like we're in
conversation in terms of like
collaborating on the like higher level
choices of this of the game because
those have kind of long been made long
you know long ago right it's an
interesting difference between this and
film the thing in my
career that even just now I've been I've
been dealing with is trying to make high
level changes too late
so
there's this this team that I've been
working with is cool and if they were
like well how about we bring you in
early on and when we're workshopping
this we can actually
get more into the nuts and bolts of why
the scene is being written what the
scene needs to accomplish and the thing
that's a really commend this team for
that ultimately with the game gets
released you'll see is that they
understand that if they're writing a
scene has nothing to do with the game
it has everything to do with character
or story there will be something that
they want to make sure that the
characters are speaking to about
something that's happening in the game
so it's not this completely Divergent
thing but I think it's it's a trap that
a lot of people fall into which is let's
write a scene
and have actors act out talking about
the game and that doesn't matter because
if it's something cool that should be
happening in the game The Players should
be doing it if we make the characters do
it it should be something that that the
player doesn't want to do or can do
so I was trying to have that
conversation far too Downstream and
thinking that that you like you said
that that that's a conversation that
could be had on the day as opposed to
and I think I've told this story here
but I've told many times other places
Brian Fleming who's the the studio head
at
um
Sucker Punch is the one that first
introduced me to the notion he was like
the pages that we're handing to you have
blood on that man all the wars that
you're trying to fight have already been
waged one and lost and you have great
ideas but you need to be in the room
not on the stage and
then I talked to Craig Mason
and I say you know when you write your
script and I I was fortunate enough to
read the pilot script for the HBO series
and it's one of the best Pilots that
I've ever read I mean it's just it's so
good it's tight it's it's I can't
captivating it's it's yeah I can't wait
either but the the thing that I asked
him is like you really spell out a lot
he goes like I totally direct from the
page I'm like but I thought you weren't
supposed to do that I thought that was
like amateur stuff he's like no that
totally directed the page like
but what about
the director that's going to be there
because you're not necessarily he's not
necessarily directing the episode or
the actor could be like well I want to
interpret it this way he's like great
then we can go to that conversation
that's fine he's like but I at least
want to get out
my perspective and what I want to get
out of this and then
like that to be clear like having a
specific position just as a starting
point is essential because otherwise
people think you don't know what you're
doing or worried I think the other
another another key difference I think
in the game side to why I understand
from TV and film is the number of people
around the table who are actually making
decisions and they're actually able to
kind of put that input in if you're
working on a film so I presume if if the
guy holding the mic is like I think we
should probably shoot this a different
way because it would make my life easier
that's not necessarily going to go down
very well right or that's not
necessarily going to be heard on a big
on a big kind of set whereas I think in
games like well first of all we're
inventing the boom mic every [ __ ]
time we make a game working that out but
you're also like but you're also just
kind of constantly in this discussion so
there isn't a sense there is no moment
where like you come down with the the
stone tablets that say this is the game
we're making it's collaborative from day
one it has to be there's no other way to
make a video game because it's just such
a complex interlocking set of systems
and then I think what's what can work is
what you're saying is kind of siloing
off like going okay no the scenes the
the cutscenes in this game they are
going to be kind of a separated thing
um but I'm yeah I'm that's expensive
it's also kind of it's definitely like
just not kind of my kind of way of
making eggs but I totally see it as a
way of doing it it's a way of doing that
in a way that kind of contains it and
allows you to tell a good story for sure
it's something that I would
scream to my younger self and I would at
the very least lied to
actors especially getting into this
medium and and without
dredging
um
yeah
understand that when when Alana said
collaboration that
that word and and the notion of
partnership
does carry some weight however do you
understand that the the point where
they're bringing you in for
collaboration the point that they're
bringing you in for partnership
is like you said so far down the line
that is a main that I'm any less
important that doesn't there's a there's
a reason why it's been
tens of thousands of dollars on casting
they spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars on actors they spend millions of
dollars potentially on shooting those
scenes they that there is a there is a
Earnest desire to make those
performances be
the next whatever the next standard and
the next Bastion yeah but it is
important to understand
that we do have a very precious place
within this medium but it is there is a
place for it
and it has to be it has to be dealt with
in a very delicate way
um
I I think it's just I I made the mistake
of overestimating
um my influence and Brian Fleming again
was a great uh person to point this out
he was like you're a very powerful for
us I said thank you he goes That's not a
compliment where you're trying to exact
change
is is too far down the river and it's
actually destructive and so I think it's
important for actors that are moving
into this meeting to understand that we
do have a lot of power when we are when
it's costing us 65 to 75 000 a day to
shoot that scene that day
um and we go I have an idea I have the
ability if I want to to bring that
entire process to a grinding halt if I
want to just be difficult yeah but the
point that I'm I'm hopefully working
towards is to be able to be in the
collaboration to be a partner and to be
able to keep the wheels on the bus
moving so that we do create a scene that
someone does find memorable that does
bring the writer's words to life that
does bring the director's Vision to
fruition and that ultimately does make a
great game
well I think what you I know you
personally as well
are very interested in forming those
relationships earlier up the river and I
think that's the way to to do what
you're trying to do and to kind of have
that more of an impact is to acknowledge
the industry as it is rather than
necessarily what you wish it would be
and kind of then finally I have to run
feel free to keep going [ __ ] off sorry
all right I'll let you keep going uh but
I gotta bounce
so it was just going to whittle down
until one of you is monologuing all
right I'll do it
um It's Gonna be Me I I do think that
um I would encourage I mean this is kind
of become like an actor's thing I
suppose but
if if you get a significant role in a
game then I I would highly recommend
um it's it's a very
delicate balance to strike and I'd be
curious to see what you think about this
but I think it's I I've seen value in in
letting the the dev know
um and the creatives know it's like man
I'm I'm sold out for this like I'm I
want to do my research I want to be in
as early as I can
um there's there's never enough
information there's I I'll I'll devour
it all and then at some point
understanding that I want the chair to
be offered to me as opposed to being
pulling it out myself from the table and
that's something that I still am very
cautious about
um about how I do but
as someone who is a studio head well
yeah but like what would you want to see
from an actor well it's what you said
it's it's showing that passion it's
showing passion without arrogance I
think I take to be honest that's true of
anyone you're trying to hire in the
games industry like I think I think um
there are definitely people who have uh
worked on like multiple of our games and
there are people who've worked on one of
our games and the difference in most
cases is that that's someone we want to
work with again obviously that's not the
case in all cases but like often that's
the case so there are actors who have
popped up in like
three four of our projects because
they're just bringing so much to the
table because I know that's someone
who's reliable gonna be passionate going
to bring a cool idea talk about Greg
Miller
so much easier like volume all he's got
now he's got the whole setup I'm gonna
Solitaire too we're gonna have to do it
um but no I think it's I think I think
you're very it's something you've
definitely put out there and I think
that's how you how you make it happen I
I don't have a I don't think it's that
game developers don't want to invite
more people into that process earlier I
don't think it's that I think it's just
often the case that we're problem
solvers we're we've got our budget we've
got our time we're working on this game
we're never gonna get it done until we
do
um but I think by making it known that
that's something that you're interested
in that means that like you know in
future I know I do I'm genuinely it
crosses my mind with several projects
there are several actors you're one of
them where early on in the project I'll
be like is there something for troying
this is there something I'd like to work
with trial on this and I think there's
yeah there's maybe like that's a list of
like five people maybe
um and I think that's that's what you're
trying to build up and the way you build
that up is by being professional by
being passionate by caring I think
that's the advice I give to anyone
playing coming up is to emulate be like
Troy Baker basically so that would be my
tip yeah
much like not like early Troy yeah like
90 98 late Troy the the thing that I've
realized and it's it's a really hard
pill to swallow is that we're just not
that important and I know that that's
that's really hard to hear but like even
from the audition process where I'm like
oh man I I spend like if if I if I go
out for a roll and I put myself on tape
or I meet with the producers and I do
the scene
from the second that I have said the
last word of that scene and said goodbye
and thank you and left it's all that I'm
thinking about it's all that I'm
thinking about they on the other hand
are like well that was a lot of fun I
wish I could do this all day off [ __ ]
and they open up their inbox and they're
looking at all the emails and they're
opening up their slack and they're
seeing all the things that they missed
out on while they were there doing
something fun working with actors which
is what they would love to be able to do
all day but they can't ah [ __ ] no level
design is speaking to no no that's not
right and they go about the business of
making a game
and then the meanwhile the actor is
thinking I'm thinking well they're not
texting me or they're not immediately
emailing me going holy [ __ ] dude you
have revolutionized even the notion of
what acting you've changed what we
thought
you know and if it's anything less than
that then I I failed and I'm not gonna
get it and then months go by this
project that I was on right now
months went by from like it was very
much of of the I've talked about this
before was it The Princess Bride it was
like good job Wesley
um we'll most likely kill you in the
morning you know I I keep thinking that
oh that's it I'm done and I I give up
there's no way it's going to happen but
there's been a history of that within my
my career
where I went out for a thing that I
didn't think that I was right for
I got this thing or I auditioned for the
thing and then that led to another
meaning which led to another meeting
which another meeting the thing that I'm
on right now there was more meetings on
this than anything I've ever done before
in my life and
ultimately it's it's understanding that
there's a whole other thing that they're
making besides my part of it yeah and
again it doesn't make my my thing
anything less
I don't think it's about importance I
think it's about scale I don't think
it's that you're less important well I
said it's just that there's a bunch of
other and it's and you know
it's also it's it's again like comparing
it to like film or TV it's like
games in my opinion likely will never be
at a point where a game gets you know
succeeds at a pitch because it's got an
actor attached that's I just don't think
that's the power or the sway that held
here
um but yeah you know if I'm if I'm right
if I want to make a movie I write my
script first thing I'm doing is trying
to find a star to attach to it right
because that's that's what gives you the
rocket fuel on on some level right
whereas I would not go I would not be
able to do that with a game like that
would not no one would there is a metric
there is a like literally people can say
if you get X actor in your movie we know
that that equates to x amount in foreign
and domestic so like there's a number
attached to it so if you write your
scripts there isn't it we can't really
engage way more I can't say and then
what the dollar value of Troy Baker in
my game is there is one absolutely
nothing value there's a creative value
but I couldn't put it all subjective
all subjective because it's also the the
barrier of Entry the ticket price is
different like if I go all right uh
George Clooney and Julia Roberts that
their new movie ticket to Paradise is
doing really really well
um we still want to see those two and
it's some romantic comedy absolutely why
not I'll pay
15 pounds or or whatever you know you
know 20 bucks or whatever it is to go
see it's pretty much across the board I
can say 15 whatever it's all equal now
it's really weird
[Laughter]
um but that that there's a number
attached to that but also it's like at
the most it's gonna cost me 20 bucks
if I look and go I really like Norman
Reedus
oh wow Norman Reedus is in a game I've
never played a game before but I really
like Norman Reedus What's it gonna cost
for me to play this game with Norman
Reedus sticks hundred dollars
there's a big difference for that and
has nothing to do with with Norman
Reedus has nothing to do with the game
has everything to do with the barrier of
Entry is way harder and the amount of
people that have the accessibility to
either watch a movie on a streaming
platform or go to the theater is way
more broad than it is someone who even
has a PS5
and I'll literate in watching movies
right they're able to they're not
freaking out a controller they're not
confused by what dual thumbstick means
like the the film literacy is almost
ubiquitous right like most people could
watch a movie and be entertained by It
games are way below that level and and
possibly will be for
a long time like and it's interesting
seeing like um we did um a d23 we we
obviously announced our thing but I was
there with um Amy Amy
um who's doing interesting stuff and and
with like the more accessibles I can't
remember what she announced I'm gonna
keep my mouth shut but like how do you
make how do you make these kind of games
appeal to uh to or accessible to a
broader audience and that stuff's
fascinating I think it's really
interesting
um yeah so I think there's there's
definitely
there's a long way to go but in that
scenario where gaming is ubiquitous
maybe Stars start to happen again maybe
we start to see actors kind of
lifted in that way the thing that I do
see happening is that there are people
who are genuine Gamers that also like
uh that are that are stars that are
Gamers oh yeah
um
uh like going to actors like when they
know yeah when they know what the medium
is that's 100 for sure have you seen
this course of your career that the like
when you're talking to other actors who
are not necessarily specifically like
Game actors that has that changed in the
time you've been working absolutely yeah
absolutely so there's now this
understanding of and I think we've also
seen that in like a perfect example is
Craig Mason so you have this huge
showrunner that is a die-hard gamer and
you also have you know uh there's a far
you know more people in the industry
besides Craig that are
outside
the mainstream I guess
that are that are Gamers that are now
operating within the
Fincher is one who's not a gamer at all
um and and like actively it came at to
an extent right like doesn't want to
play games thinks games are for dweebs
that kind of guy I'm assuming it's it's
not that games are for dweebs we uh we
had a great conversation where he said
um he had a pitch for a game or he was
brought into to consult on the game and
and he was like let me let me tell you
what I would do for this and he he
walked me through step by step I was
like [ __ ] that's that's great and he
starts off this scene as a premise to
set up this this game
and he was like but the problem is he
was like that's a movie that's not a
game and the second that you let the the
player do something
it's now out of your control and you
can't do that is you can't tell a story
David in his face he's very controlling
of how his story is told that's shocking
information because he knows it's always
focused on the detail at all he knows
exactly what it's supposed to look like
and so it's like so I said all right let
me tell you a story
and I said you have
um you have this guy and he is a a good
guy hard worker a single dad
um
World breaks you know all hell breaks
loose World goes in chaos daughter dies
flash forwards 20 years and I walk him
through beat by beat one and uh part one
in part two and I said so then you have
you know Dad dies makes surrogate
daughter New Daughter who does this and
he goes
it's in a video game
all right that's a good story who was
the director I was like his name is Neil
truckman
um so I I I understand his point where
again
at some point you are I can't expect I
can't look at a book and go why are you
not letting me be interactive at some
point the medium is what the medium is
and
the people I think there's nothing wrong
with that directing yeah the people who
are working in the media
want that it's it's that collaborative
thing again I had to I go I remember
like arguing with another Indie Dev ones
because they were complaining that um uh
we were at an event so we're both
demoing our games and a streamer walked
past and got an enormous audience just
kind of runs over to the streamer and
and this guy I'm talking to is like we
make the things why why is a kid just
because he plays stuff he gets that
audience I'm like you think you're David
Beckham but you're the guy making the
shoes like and it's okay but like right
what's your role in this you are making
them you're making a thing that empowers
other people either you know publicly or
privately to express themselves that's
where a different we're not going to be
the Stars we're not the focus of this
the player is
um and yeah it's a whole different
medium because of that and then I can I
can totally understand if you're someone
who works in like a linear media giving
up that level of control must be
impossible to imagine because you're so
used to having that finite it was
something that was really fun with with
the um the audiobook that you joined in
with if we did not start Rising like
just writing a story and not having to
think about the player in that and just
going I'm just going to tell a fun
little little adventure story was such a
weird and interesting experience just
because I've never done that before I've
always written interactively so yeah
it's interesting I over the last month
now it's it's I've
spent so much time and it's something
that's so foreign
being in the states to to be in a place
that does have such history
and understanding that
most of the pieces of art I was I was I
was in the loop and
this notion hit me was like
a majority of the pieces of art that I'm
looking at
are only considered art because
they're old
someone gave them a designation a number
put them behind glass and they're under
this roof but they were originally
designed to be
Pottery tools a letter to a relative it
was never made to be art it was just
we look at it we recontextualize that as
art
so I think that like like you said the
the David Beckham thing is great it's
like yeah that's the person that gets to
he couldn't do what he's doing without
what we do but we do what we do so that
he can do what he does
and he's going to get all the things and
there's pride in being cobbler it's a
fun thing to do you're making cool stuff
like
and I think that's the yeah I think yeah
it's always a conversation I think
that's the interesting thing when you
see art in a museum is
it becomes oh I was literally just about
to I was about to quote on X Games I
can't do that
I will offline tell you a line for my
next game which is this I think art is
it's very yeah anyway I can't I can't
say any of that publicly so shut the
[ __ ] up it's two minutes
ha ha
ha I edited to myself that's fine it
saves a lot I have a question for you
yeah
I I mentioned early on that the hotel
that I was at in bath
whether it's a lovely little Charming in
bath they call it bath not bath is a
southern way of saying it they wouldn't
like that what I found that was
interesting is bath spa I was like all
right you guys stop
um I went to The Abbey that was there it
was beautiful I I actually I thought
about you in I think about it I walked
huh I walk in and
I'm curious I want to see if I was right
or not no um I walk in and this um
you know this beautiful uh Abbey and I
love going into Old churches
um I love seeing the history I love
seeing
um
mainly just the history
[ __ ] I'm tired I love the two guys that
are on the longest uh uh or the latest
[ __ ] party animals so don't hate this
story and then we can then we I'll let
you go after that go for it all right so
um this woman climbs the you know if
you've ever been into like a basilica
style Church in the middle is there's
like the there's the altar down here but
then there's also the pulpits right here
she climbs up there and she says for all
of our patrons today
um this is an opportunity we're going to
say a prayer and this is the time where
we pray for world peace and and pray for
those who have been lost in war and we
just ask that you have a moment of
silence or if you want to join us in
prayer you can please have a seat
um or just stand wherever you are it was
this cool thing I've never been a part
of that before I've been in there where
there has been mass or I've been in
there where there's been a christening
some other kind of form of liturgical
activity that's happening but never been
when it's like hey we're going to do
this prayer it was for the masses
and I found myself I was sitting there
and I was like it's it's so funny
because it's more than anybody else I
was like I wonder what Mike would do
right now
and I was curious
if you were there because I set fire
immediately [ __ ] off
the honest answer is I would take a
moment and reflect I don't think there's
any I don't think there's anything wrong
as an atheist I think it's absolutely a
human thing not a religious thing to
think on things to show respect to take
a moment I think that predates any
concept of religion I think that's just
a human thing so I would reflect I would
think about the subject that was talked
about
um and I'd show respect to the space I
was in as well this is this is I'm on
someone else's I'm in someone's house
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna take my
shoes off you know what I mean like I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do things their way
so I'd be very respectful and take a
moment and think about things and then
and then head out
um and then you know I then obviously I
would just curse religiously for uh
favorites just to offset the uh just to
balance it out a little bit to be honest
the experience I know this is true of
your upbringing as well like I grew up
around religion you know I you know
there's it's it's the Church of England
we have we we have a we have an entire
church that exists because of how hot
angelin was so it's like there's a
there's a whole culture you grow up in
that you can't kind of avoid so I've
always had respect for the church and
and people I have respect for you know
good people whatever their belief system
is I disagree with them on many things
but you know
if you're a good person you're a good
person it doesn't matter what you
believe frankly I also do like I'm glad
that I was right about that because I
was I I found myself thinking that that
exact same thing you're like you are
someone who would respect where you were
at and be able to appreciate it on a
different level
and kind of the same way that I was
to where it's I'm taking this in and I
appreciate the fact that I get to be a
part of this that I'm sitting in a place
right now where four
centuries people have done this exact
thing and that alone is worthy of
you know at least remarking that at
least at least I love experiencing other
cultures like when you go to a like the
wedding of someone who's uh from a faith
that you've you've not been around much
like these elements of seeing those
cultures and seeing how things it's
always fascinating no I'm I'm if you've
never been to an Indian wedding or if
you've never been to a
um uh
a Jewish wedding
if you've never been to apparently a
Balinese funeral I don't think I've ever
been to a Jewish wedding or a balades
for you know that's those I should I
should take those off the list at some
point
this one sounds like that's that's the
psychopath thing that's uh I'm not gonna
go and kill someone to find out that but
the uh yeah sorry I just want to go
sorry I really want to experience this
um you did mention that I was a friend
of yours yeah
[Laughter]
I was gonna ask this and then we'll
leave it with this because this is
apparently a Halloween episode
um do you subscribe in any way that was
mentioning that I was in bath
and that 100 the hotel was haunted it
was just there wasn't there's no way
around it
uh it was I even asked like what was
this hotel she was like oh it was um
this part was dormitories
um but then of course it belonged to the
older men for a while I was like so it's
haunted she's like oh absolutely in fact
here's your room dude it was like
[ __ ] I turned she was gone
um but what is your do you believe in
any ass you know whatever it means uh
are there ghosts
in a in a physical literal sense I don't
believe in ghosts now I believe that I
believe similar to your paintings hang
in the Louvre I think humans are
brilliant at attaching meaning to things
and I think if ghosts exist then that is
a poem we tell ourselves about the world
we live in and I think that's if that's
that's real it exists in the sense that
it matters to people so it's real but no
I don't think there's like a magical you
know people still around kind of thing
um apparitions that people see what not
what is that
rare enough that it wouldn't be ghosts
it's my like my boring scientific answer
like just because if you think about how
many people have died in history and how
they and where they've died and how
frequently we would be seeing ghosts if
that were the case but like I said I do
have respect for it and I do
um
I think there's an I think it's
interesting that people keep telling
each other ghost stories regardless of
where those stories are true I think
there's an interesting thing that humans
Reach For That
that unknown and and either in my
opinion create mythologies or you know
find find truth it's it's interesting to
me I I feel like in this era we win
similar to UFOs it's like we've had
smartphones for a while now like someone
would have filmed something at this
point like that's that's kind of my my
take on it my whole take
Frank looked behind you but behind you
Mike
that
Halloween